i'm single
you're single
do you go on dating apps what's your
dating situation oh god
i just love to talk about it with people
okay i mean this this is a dating app
it's true i want real life i i i and and
yet we're in a pandemic and then this is
the way of the world what do you do no i
i went on every single dating app and
i'm like you know this is just insane
and then all the information and it
takes forever and who i am and what i do
and i was like do i want them to know
it's really me because i did that before
and it's just like they just wanted to
meet me and it's like oh my god and
asking me a million questions they
didn't really want to date they're like
i'm scared of you and i'm like well
you're not the right person you know
you're not strong who you are as a man
then like goodbye okay really so anyway
and i'll and then the first thing is
like you know
asking me a bunch of prince question all
right so i take pictures of myself on
the side so you can't really tell it's
me and put on a hat or something and it
just it was time-consuming just to get
through the whole process for each app
did you meet anyone did you go out
because this i did has anyone watched
and just like that
okay so in and just like that carries
like has to go on a date so she goes on
an app picks a guy and boom he meets her
at the restaurant i'm like oh this is
why hollywood screws us up so badly
that's not how it works that how many
people have gone on an app and then just
gone and met the person i mean it
happens but no i did it's rare right
yeah
you're raising your hand what's your
name nancy nancy i'm a widow
oh i'm sorry oh
thank you
um
but after he died i went on and met
somebody who was close and um i dated
him for a while
and three years later nothing
but that's how nothing that's how and
just like that starts they're both
widows on the date the first one was
good and i was pumped i'm going oh this
is easy right it's not
it is hard to date on a dating app and
if someone beautiful and stylish like
yourself nancy struggles and sheila e
struggles then i at least feel like i'm
in a great club
um wow this is really cool okay well
you're sheila e one of the greatest
drummers on the planet and i was just
wondering i know we're here in the
kitchen i heard you have a way to sort
of boost all of our spirits in the
kitchen
um
okay because well yeah this is more like
kitchen x sheila e
no this is this is great teach me sheila
oh look at this we have stuff okay so i
grew up playing pots and pans first so i
yeah i did so i just took stuff you know
you can you can you can just make it up
you know
oh that is a nice sound
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay i'll go slower everyone has rhythm
by the way
uh if your heart didn't beat you
wouldn't be here
your heartbeat is the first rhythm come
on now
come on
i already lost you okay so what do i do
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
thank you
if your heart
beats you have rhythm absolutely it
starts with your heartbeat always so
perfect
sheila e thank you so much you're
welcome may we all advocate for those we
love
thank you sheila e be sure to check out
her new music video by laura the salsa
version and her show sheila e tv perfect
on youtube it's phenomenal
[Music]
you